what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so continuing our discussions on
blackest night at this point we pick up
with the second part and this focuses
partly on the Green Lantern Corps and
the second half on the Green Lantern
title itself again much like we did in
the previous video now in the last video
we had basically dealt with this idea
that there were two things happening in
the universe at the same time I mean the
black lantern rings are basically these
rings that attach themselves to those
who have been deceased and they
resurrect them for the purpose of
emotionally charging other individuals
so that when those individuals and
hearts are just filled with all
different types of emotions the Black
Lantern takes their heart consumes it
and it feeds their central power battery
charging it up to 100% now the idea here
is that in the last video we basically
mentioned that the Black Lantern rings
basically spreading throughout the
universe was a massive calamity because
what it meant is that individuals who
had died across the universe were being
resurrected no matter what planet they
were on and we even saw entire planets
being resurrected by the Black Lantern
rings now of course all this goes
towards the entity of necron which is to
say in the DC universe when it comes to
the emotional spectrum you've got
entities that represent those spectrums
they're not really gods they're really
more just kind of like avatars and so
Necron is kind of this living embodiment
of death so to speak but the idea here
is that the goal of the black Lantern's
is to basically charge the central power
battery to 100% so that it will
basically open a gateway and allow
necron to enter the living realm and all
this is important because of the fact
that this feeds into the war of light it
feeds into the rise of the black
Lantern's all these Lantern cores go in
to war against one another while that's
happening the black Lantern's rising to
prominence ultimately eliminating all
life in existence and then assuring and
this basically blackest night this
eternal darkness in the universe and so
with the Green Lantern Corps this again
focuses on basically everybody except
for kal Jordan the main Green Lantern
quote-unquote in the DC Universe and so
we basically end up picking up with like
cirrhotic not to you and these
characters and we had talked about how
the black Lantern's were really sadistic
because they would basically kill
anybody in this instance it was the
black Lantern's going to the infirmary
of the Green Lantern Corps and then with
those individuals who were effectively
injured or who were basically unable to
defend themselves the black Lantern's
would terrify them and when their hearts
were charged they would just seize them
and take their hearts out of their
bodies so they were basically killing
helpless people so it's pretty insane in
terms of how that
but again that becomes significant
because it's like classic zombie
infection the more zombies there are the
more zombies there become just because
the Black Lanterns once they kill
someone a Black Lantern ring suddenly
bonds to that person and the numbers
bolster even further and so that's what
this is this is a continuation of the
idea that the Green Lantern Corps is
basically coming to the realization that
the dead are rising in the form of black
Lantern's
and the goal is to get as many people
out there as they possibly can the
problem with this is that each
individual member at least the most
prominent members of the Green Lantern's
are dealing with the black Lantern's in
their own individual way now this is
something that happens across the board
for cirrhotic not to she's basically the
the top medic the top doctor of the
Green Lantern Corps and so to see
individuals being killed and then turned
into black Lantern's is her own way of
basically having to deal with being
confronted by the Black Lantern concept
now this means the black Lantern's
themselves will fill her heart with
emotion with rage with fear with
willpower so on and so forth and they'll
try to take her out as well but what had
happened over the course of the Green
Lantern Corps line of stories by Peter
Selassie as he began focusing on this
idea that a kind of affection was
brewing between ceramic natsu and kyle
rayner as a green lantern now in all
honesty this just made good sense it's
basically this idea that a lot of the
girlfriends of kyle rayner were his were
like you know heroic or they were very
virtuous but with cirrhotic not to she
basically possesses all those character
traits she's headstrong she's brave
she's got the drive war accounts she's
got ambition her goal is to be one of
the greatest Green Lantern's and so it
was basically Peter J Tomasi coming
along and saying we're going to
introduce a love interest between Kyle
Rayner and cirrhotic not to you but
she's not gonna go out the same way as
everybody else the cool thing about this
is that with Kyle raiders most recent
girlfriend the girl by the name of Jade
who was basically the daughter of the
Green Lantern Alan Scott what happened
is that she essentially sacrificed her
life in order to save Kyle Rayner also
imbued him with something called the
star heart which is basically a version
of the Green Lantern energy from a
different reality and the idea here was
that it helped to bolster the powers of
collimator which words him being ion we
talked about that in a previous video
well the long and short of this is that
Jade had basically been resurrected by a
black lantern and much like all the
black lanterns that we've seen so far
the goal is emotional manipulation
feed on their emotional state whatever
relationship they have charged their
hearts with energy
and then take their heart when it's
filled with emotion Jade had initially
appeared to kyle rayner as hey it's okay
that I I pass you know that's that's the
way things go but we can be together
again and this kind of hope you know
this blue lantern energy of hope filled
kyle rayner it was also real power it
was also the belief that maybe things
can work out but it was really Col Elena
putting on a ruse that he was playing
along with Jade to understand the
motivations of what the Black Lanterns
were looking for and that's when Kyle
Rayner came to the realization the black
Lantern's are looking to charge people's
hearts with emotion and then consume
them now in the middle of all this
because Jade had such an emotional and
psychological impact on Kyle Rayner it
takes the intervention of ceramic not to
just sort of snap go in or out
completely in the sense that he's aware
of what it is at Jade's doing but his
heart can't help but feel that maybe
they can be together again now of course
again so rynek Natsu has no stake in
Jade she doesn't know Jade she's never
met Jade and so cirrhotic not - is the
voice of reason here she's the one that
essentially kind of defies at all and
jumps into the fray now the other half
of this are characters like Kilowog
right for Kilowog he doesn't really have
a whole lot of emotional attachments to
other people that are out there for him
he's the drill sergeant of the Green
Lantern Corps he's very militaristic in
that fashion and so for him it's honor
and duty above all else but as the drill
sergeant for the Green Lantern every
single Green Lantern that dies feels
like it's the fault of Kilowog and
that's what the black Lantern's feed on
in his case is this idea all these
different black Lantern's out here there
were formerly Green Lantern's who died
in the line of duty they would have died
if you done your job like you were
supposed to and that's what fills them
with rage because remember no matter
what any of these Green Lantern Corps
members feel the black Lantern's will
feed on it but one of the darkest
moments comes from out of this and we
basically find out that the children of
Cribb have all come back as black
Lantern's
now crib was a character who was I
believe originally introduced in the
Sinestro Corps war but crib was
basically this weird alien entity that
essentially went on this pattern of
killing Green Lantern's and then taking
their children and making the children
her own now she wasn't like abusing them
or anything she would just take them
whisk them off to some planet somewhere
and say you are now my children but the
idea is that for whatever reason that
hasn't been explained yet these kids
have all basically died now this can
largely be due to the be attributed to
the fact that crib was the only one
taking care of these kids
and with crib basically having been
captured by the Green Lanterns and then
allowed to go with the zamarons the star
sapphires these kids were just kind of
left to their own devices and ultimately
ended up just perishing according to the
environment but the problem is that in
the middle of all this we end up having
the arrival of one of the Indigo
lanterns now again when it comes to the
black lanterns the only way to truly
defeat them is to blast them with just a
massive amount of just bright energy
basically white light and the way in
which you can pull that off is by
combining rings together or something
along those lines by blasting them with
a massive amount of light energy what it
does is it creates a feedback in the
ring basically causes the ring to
essentially overload and the result is
that this feedback resonates throughout
the black lantern themselves they simply
just explode but what this does you know
with the arrival of these kids with the
arrival of the Indigo tribes showing up
and basically helping the Green
Lantern's to stave off the Black Lantern
Corps we switch our focus to the red
lanterns now again we talked about this
in the last video in the sense that the
red lanterns were basically dealing with
the aftermath of the Green Lantern's
trying to retrieve one of their own who
had previously perished and in the
middle of this whole conflict you know
what the Green Lantern's being the only
ones really left there the Black Lantern
rings started descending on everybody
and what happens is four of the five
inversions are basically resurrected now
the fifth inversion is Atrocitus himself
the person who created the Red Lantern
Corps but to provide a little bit of
history for those of you guys who are
watching this video for the first time
the first thing I would suggest is
checking out the origin of the red
lanterns that way you'll fully
understand who the five inversions are
but the long and short of this is that
before the green lanterns were ever
created by the guardians of the universe
the guardians of the universe had
created the Manhunters and the
Manhunters are basically just robots and
the belief of the guardians is that
because the robots only do what they're
told they're the perfect form to
basically police the universe to make
sure that there is no credible threats
with regards to people trying to
obliterate planets or anything along
those lines the problem is that the the
Manhunters malfunction and will actually
find out later on down the line that it
was one of the Guardians themselves that
caused it to happen but the idea is that
what the Manhunter is basically going
awry they traveled to Sector 666 and
basically killed everyone and so what
ended up happening is the survivors of
Sector 666 these five inversions came
together in their hatred for the
guardians of the universe and began the
process of plotting and trying to find a
way to eliminate the guardians in their
entire
along with the newly-formed Green
Lantern Corps and so we're Atrocitus was
one of the five inversions and it
basically seen a vision of the future
with regards to what's actually
happening right now
what he in turn did is killed the other
four inversions and then created the Red
Lantern Court and so that's why these
inversions are resurrecting is because
these are the people that Atrocitus
killed and so in this instance with the
four inversions popping up as black
lanterns
Atrocitus is fearless and doesn't care
because he's so full with rage because
rage is the one governing force of his
life his heart was already charged with
full emotion but the caveat to this and
remember when it comes to the red
lanterns when they're given a Red
Lantern ring it replaces their heart and
so where the black Lantern's attack
trosset us for the purpose of taking his
heart and consuming it his heart will
inevitably regrow now this has both a
benefit and a drawback the benefit is
that they can't kill attrocities by
tearing his heart out which means the
Red Lanterns cannot be killed by the
black lanterns and the red lanterns
themselves cannot become black lanterns
unless of course the ring is taken away
the drawback to this is they are
basically an infinite source of emotion
as long as they keep like red lanterns
prisoner black lanterns could literally
just repeatedly tear out their hearts
and consume them until they charge the
central power battery that's why this
threat of the black lanterns has to be
dealt with as fast as humanly possible
but in this instance because Atrocitus
is basically the living embodiment of
rage the black lanterns don't stand a
chance you know him blasting them with
massive amounts of energy and so on and
so forth again causes these black
lanterns to come crashing down and so
what this does is basically transition
to this third part of the story this
last little bit where we basically pick
up with Hal Jordan the Green Lantern we
pick up with Sinestro and we pick up
with the Indigo tribe as well as the
Star Sapphire this comes out of the idea
that with Sinestro having been
imprisoned by the Green Lantern's after
the event of the Sinestro Corps war it
allowed a villain by the name of Mongol
one of the most notable enemies in DC
and someone who's basically equal to
Superman in strength in a lot of ways to
rise to power after receiving a yellow
lantern ring and then basically take
over the Sinestro Corps himself and so
what this did is once thousand estra was
freed from his imprisonment in the midst
of the rise of the black lanterns he
went out he basically tried to seize
back control of his Sinestro Corps and
the first stop was xamarin the home of
the star sapphires because the star
sapphires
in a number of the Sinestro Corps and
tried to convert them into star
sapphires and so because of that
Sinestro arriving is also met with the
Indigo tribe you know indigo one who had
basically snatched Hal Jordan from Earth
brought him over to xamarin in an effort
to basically start uniting the different
cores and again that's the basis of the
Indigo tribe the Indigo tribe is a
Lantern Corps of compassion but they're
also the Lantern Corps of reason and
logic and so this basically puts us
where we are right now with regards to a
little bit of infighting in the sense
that we have Hal Jordan and Sinestro
bickering among one another but it's
basically this idea that we have to
begin working together we have to
function as a cohesive unit because if
we don't this war of light will consume
us all and the black lanterns will just
bring about the end of all things in the
universe so ultimately what this does is
again this picks up a little bit with
regards to the blue lanterns and the
orange lanterns remember the orange
lanterns are basically the Lantern Corps
of greed of avarice but instead of
having an actual core it's basically
just Larfleeze himself in the sense that
his core consists of constructs but the
blue lanterns are basically a lantern
core based on hope it's the idea that no
matter how bad things get there's always
a way to overcome things and so the
power of the blue lanterns can only
really stand some measure when it's
accompanied by the powers of the green
lanterns the green lanterns are kind of
the foundation that powers the Blue
Lantern Corps and that's why in this
instance despite the fact that the blue
lanterns are largely considered to be
the most powerful they're really
struggling against the orange lanterns
because there's no green lanterns there
to bolster their own power but this
changes when indigo one brings Hal
Jordan and Sinestro and Star Sapphire
directly to where it is the blue
lanterns are at because again the green
lanterns bolster the Blue Lantern power
and the Blue Lantern rings can
supercharge the Green Lantern ring so
they're designed to basically work
together but this allows the blue
lanterns the power they need facing
against Larfleeze the problem is that in
the middle of all this all the orange
constructs vanish and the reason for
this is because Larfleeze recalled them
all to himself because of the fact that
again the black lantern range descended
on Larfleeze his base of operations and
began bonding themselves to all these
people Larfleeze had killed in his greed
and in his hubris and so with this in
mind the Larfleeze basically begins to
panic and basically begins to run off
but is met by the arrival of Atrocitus
who basically shows up having defeated
all four inversions and the black
lanterns on his own home
with the intention of not only seizing
the orange Lantern ring for himself but
using it with his own abilities because
what it would do is would bolster the
power of the red lanterns in terms of
the fact that he's able to use two
different rings at the same time so
again Atrocitus his motivation is to
still take out all the different Lantern
cores to basically ensure that the guard
is the university' feeted and so on and
so forth he's not yet been recruited to
the cause of all the other lanterns he's
not yet been told here's everything
that's going on he's aware of the
prophecy of blackest night he's aware of
what it means but he doesn't really seem
to grasp the idea that if the prophecy
of blackest night rises to its full
fruition everybody will die including
him and the red lanterns themselves but
with that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to comment explain and
make sure you guys with the sub button
to become part of the robb cork if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
you